okay YouTube I am back with the vlog
finally I'm so happy to be back
should we go show him the tree Kylie
Jenner is back on YouTube and she's in
the holiday spirit
I miss you should we show him the
Christmas decorations after a month I'm
not posting to YouTube Kiley shared this
vlog taking fans with her as she went to
a rescue mission and she showed us her
insanely magical Christmas decor
alongside to hunter stormy okay that's
gonna look at the Christmas tree it's
crazy
and get this Kylie's home is filled with
Santa's galore all right so we have like
big Santa's everywhere eating him a hug
we have this big one can you find Santa
for me on the tree and guys it turns out
Kylie's just like she got most of her
jetkor from Target on this console table
here I have a ceramic little town I
think it's really cute I'm pretty sure I
got this from Target I got most of my
stuff from Target I set up the little
deer these candles by the way are
everything what do they make your house
smell like Christmas
who would've thought Kylie can be
hashtag relatable
I think these Santa matches are so cute
I got those from literally Bristol Farms
especially because she's you know a
billionaire and just sold half of her
cosmetics Empire for six hundred million
dollars she built a business off of
something that she first was insecure
about and finding confidence and tapping
into that and figuring out how to make
an amazing product and just being true
to herself and doing what she loves to
do that's so inspiring and so amazing
and I'm so proud of her
Kylie also got pretty sentimental with
us revealing why she decorated the way
she did I love this because I wanted to
store me too
kind of experience what I used to
experience growing up and all the
amazing memories that I have these
ornaments my mom had and I used to love
sitting by the tree they're all
different and just looking at all of
them so I wanted the same thing for
stormy so I got all these ornaments for
her because I think they're so
traditional and cute also it turns out
stormy is quite the artiste
Julie she's also got a little bit of
sass which I love
okay you want to be beep cutest now no
word on if Stormies dad Travis Scott
will be spending the holidays with the
car Jenner's but he did spend Halloween
with Kylie and stormy at the time source
told ET they aren't back together but
neither are seeing anyone else right now
I feel like if people want to if my
truth is or want to know first
alright guys that's it for today for all
the latest on Kylie and the rest of her
family et until next time I'm Katie
crafts and bye for now
[Music]